wearing of course
[Applause]
perhaps anonymous with texas just in
case you've forgotten where he landed
[Applause]
well there you go greg happy scenes as
that
first space trip by jeff bezos
company blue origin touches down
um the big question is i suppose
what does happen next like you said
virgin who
got there first are planning to open up
commercial space travel
next year how far does this go because
there has been a lot of talk of
the commercial activity that will
surround it but also what they're doing
in terms of space
exploration which you know given the
headlines you know it's billionaires up
in space it seems to get
lost what do we know about what they're
actually doing up there that might be of
use
yeah and both all of the companies
involved in this are are
pursuing this twin track if you like
this is this is the glamour the
few minutes of weightlessness at the
edge of space that that
a few rich people might be able to
afford but uh blue origin was working
with nasa on a moon lander
it lost out in that race to spacex
spacex of course has been taking
uh crew and cargo to the international
space station
uh virgin as well as virgin galactic
this virgin orbit which is a sister
company that launches satellites into
space from
from an airliner that's that's showing
great success so
they are part of this this bigger story
which is nasa wanting to move away from
purely public funding for space
exploration and letting it become more
commercial allowing companies to
to take some of the risk and spacex have
been have been way ahead in that game
um and then there is this other side to
it of what is the what is the future of
of taking people into space what is the
point
uh for humanity for this planet beyond
just joy rides for
four millionaires those are questions
they still got to answer but
a big part of this was showing it was
viable and realistic
and safe with all of the risks of course
in space travel
and they've done that richard branson
first now jeff bezos are showing you can
go up to space and come back safely in a
few minutes
and that for the people who can afford
it will be a a real
a very strong advertisement i'm sure